do you know this guy right here Bernard
Arno he's the richest man in the world
and the CEO and the chairman of a luxury
fashion brand Louis Vuitton Moya
Hennessy on the outside his company is
Iconic for their flamboyant purses and
the bags coming in and added thousands
of dollars each but on the inside
there's nothing flamboyant about the
company or Bernard whatsoever this makes
sense because Bernard didn't found a
single one of the dozens of fashion
brands that he owns today he actually
got a start in his family's construction
business which gave him enough money to
buy out the parent company of a
Christian Dior from there he would
engage in constant corporate raiding
hostile takeovers and brutal
backstabbing to build the Empire that is
lvmh today they've bought out everyone
from Tiffany and Bulgari to Sephora and
Hermes in fact here's a list of all the
brands that lvmh currently owns or has
owned in the past with each and every
one of these Brands Bernardo followed a
very simple formula by a substantial
predatory stake in a business of her
liking promise that you're not looking
to take over the company engineer
internal strife amongst the existing
team and finally make them an offer they
can't refuse in the meantime he's also
been Keen to ensure that he doesn't get
overthrown himself one of the first
things he did after taking over lvmh was
acquire enough shares to form a blocking
minority which means that no one can
successfully challenge his power over
the company while toxic the strategy has
played out in Bernard's favor way more
often than not I mean that's why he's
the richest person in the world but
there are a few notable exceptions as
was the case with Gucci Bernard
approached Gucci just like he did with
any other brand but little did he know
Gucci would put up the fight of their
lives and this takeover would end up
being one of Bernard's most public
failures so here's a Louis Vuitton got
humiliated trying to take over Gucci
taking a look back the bloody battle for
Gucci dates back to early 1999. the CEO
of Gucci Domenico de Soul had to just
put in a stellar year with Gucci she
added nearly doubled the stock price
from 32 dollars to 56 dollars and the
star designer Tom Ford was making heads
turn up around the world Gucci was no
longer the struggling business desperate
for a bailout that they were just five
years ago when the soul took over but
the soul was just getting started yes he
had successfully rescued the company
from bankruptcy but he wasn't just
looking to save the company what he
wanted to do was make Gucci a fashion
giant that was feared and respected
around the world and last year's stock
performance was exactly the momentum
that daso needed to make this Evolution
but there was one Fury in the back of
his mind Bernard Arnold for the past
year rumors had gone rampant then
Bernard was looking to take over Gucci
on the outside the soul would put on a
brave man facade that he wasn't worried
about Bernard or his predatory hobby but
internally the soul was petrified he had
only been CEO for five years but he had
been involved with the Gucci since the
early 1980s and this was by far his
life's greatest work so you can bet that
desol had no intention of giving Gucci
up to some French wolf just so that he
could add it to his endless list of
Brands as a result their soul was
keeping a close pulse on the situation
he would regularly call Gucci's
investment banker Morgan Stanley and
inquire if any outsized purchases of
Gucci stock had been made in fact he
wouldn't make one such call on this
fateful day January 5th 1999 but
something was different today as they
saw felt that they were finally out of
the woods instead of inquiring about any
large purchases he would probably tell
the banker it looks like we're in the
clearance
but it was only hours later that he
would get a frantic call from his
assistant Louis Vuitton's president
carcel who was also an old friend of the
Soul was on the line but almost
instantaneously desol could tell that
Carson wasn't calling to get Rings or
discuss the fashion industry parcel was
calling to inform he was calling to
inform that lvmh had acquired a five
percent stake in Gucci and it that the
news was gonna go public later that day
he went on to assure day so that
Bernard's purchase was nothing but
passive and that he wanted the two
Brands to work together but knowing
Bernard's history they saw knew that
this was complete and utter BS he would
hang up the phone and rush into the
London Gucci office calling everyone
that he could think of he called him
Morgan Stanley he called her
anti-takeover specialist and then his
heart sunk the anti-takeover Specialists
that they had been working with forever
just happened to have a one year long
sabbatical starting in just one week at
this point they saw lost it he hung up
the phone and hollered if Arno wants the
company he can have it I don't give a
blank I'll just go sailing
though day Soul had a little Outburst
there he by no means meant what he said
though he did love sailing him he wasn't
gonna sit back and let this French
Tycoon bully Gucci so he would call back
Morgan Stanley and ask to get in contact
with the boss of his former
anti-takeover specialist this got him in
contact with a man named Michael zawi
who was the head of Morgan Stanley's
European merger Advisory Group normally
such a defense would have been under his
pay grade but zawi was more than happy
to help because he had his own Vendetta
against Arno you see he had previously
represented the Guinness Brewery in
their own fight against lvmh just a few
years ago and that fight didn't go as
well as Sally had hoped so this was his
chance to get revenge he would come over
to the Gucci office in a matter of
minutes bringing with Emma Morgan
Stanley's defense but when they opened
up the file they would be met with
another bombshell it turns out that the
anti-takeover specialist wasn't just
going on a sabbatical but he hadn't done
it Jack in terms of creating a defense
in fact the entire defense consisted of
just two closets one day Soul was
allowed to resign from the company in
the event of a hostile takeover and two
Tom Ford was also allowed to resign if
someone acquired more than 35 percent
zawi couldn't believe it he would call
up his employee and yell where is the
effing defense what have you guys been
doing at all this time to this the
employee didn't really have a response
and it wouldn't be surprising if this
guy's sabbatical turned into a permanent
one but that didn't really help Gucci's
case as a Gucci CFO observed it you guys
are toast for Gucci there was really
only one way out of this they would have
to find someone else to buy a large
enough steak in Gucci before lvmh took
over this way lvmh wouldn't be able to
acquire a majority but this was a much
easier said than done here's the thing
Gucci was worth 8.7 billion dollars and
while this was cheap money for Bernard
for everyone else in the fashion
industry this was a serious business and
they couldn't just make an investment
decision overnight so they solo only had
one option try his best to stop Bernard
but Bernard had no intention of moving
slow just a few days after his initial
purchase lvmh would acquire another 9.5
stake in Gucci and within 10 days
Bernard would own over a quarter of the
company in the meantime they saw was
desperately calling every CEO in the
fashion industry pleading for them to
invest in Gucci or at the very least not
sell off any stick that they may already
have but call after Cola they solo was
politely refused for all the other CEOs
making Bernard into an enemy was simply
eroded they didn't want to go down given
that no one else wanted to help Gucci
they so knew that there was only one
more person to ask Bernard himself he
would set up a meeting with Bernard at
Morgan Stanley and request that he
slowed down his body and let Gucci stay
independent Bernard was apparently open
to the request but in return he wanted
it three full seats on the Gucci board
and it became clear to the soul right
then and there that Bernardo wasn't here
for a compromise he was just looking to
grow his control in Gucci through
another Avenue so they still would of
course reject this offer but this simply
led to Bernard upping his take to 34.4
percent Bernard was taunting Gucci just
another 0.6 percent and that Tom Ford
could leave with no repercussions
despite Bernard's Charming personality
this was a no-friendly deal this was war
and it was now a Do or Die for Gucci
baseball wasn't done and begging
everyone into your fashion industry even
if someone wanted to help Bernard would
probably just destroyed them as well so
what Gucci had to do was Fight Fire with
Fire and after Consulting with the slew
of lawyers he knew exactly what to do he
was gonna dilute lvma just take it into
Oblivion you know how companies like to
buy back their shares to increase their
stock price well they can do the
opposite to it and issue a bunch of
shares for obvious reasons companies
avoided doing this unless they really
need to raise money Gucci didn't need
money but they could issue a crap ton of
shares to dilute Bernard Bernard on the
other hand was well aware of the
strategy but he thought he was protected
you see American regulation specifies
that companies can't dilute more than 20
of their company without a special
waiver this is obviously to protect
shareholders from over dilution so
Bernard figured worst case scenario if
Gucci tried to pull the stunt he'd have
to pay another 20 for the company no big
deal also there was no way Gucci would
get a waiver just to stop an acquisition
waivers are reserved for truly dark
situations as in this company will go
bankrupt if they don't dilute more Gucci
was obviously not in that position so
Bernard was quite confident in his own
position but it turns out that Bernard's
lawyers had missed out on some fine
print you see it that 20 rule only
applied to American companies so
technically Gucci was legally allowed to
dilute themselves into Oblivion of
course this would hurt all Gucci
shareholders but given that lvmh was the
biggest one they would be hurt the most
and with that they saw started printing
shares left and right little to say
Bernard was truly pissed and he would
decide to leverage some fine print
himself according to Gucci's own bylaws
anyone would mistake larger than 10
could request a special shareholder
meeting at this meeting Bernard wanted
to nominate a new prison to the Gucci
board and essentially stage a coup
things were getting heated fast and the
de soul needed a power play to get the
upper hand while printing shares could
stall it didn't solve the issue of not
having a large stakeholder that could
block out lvmh Gucci's resilience and
the willingness to fight Elvia major
they depict the interest of more
potential buyers but no one was planning
to pull the trigger just yet but they
saw didn't have time to burn so he
decided if I can't find a shareholder
I'll just create one I'll give all the
shares to Gucci employees through a
massive Employee Stock ownership plan or
ESOP and that's exactly what he did in
late February of 1999 Gucci issued a 20
million shares to their employees which
effectively diluted Bernard from 35 down
to 25 percent for the first time Bernard
could feel Gucci slipping from his grips
but the fight was far from over
This brilliant move from Gucci turned
heads not just within the fashion
industry but the business world as a
whole but while this was a great victory
for Gucci they still didn't let this
distract him from his end goal which was
to escape the clutches of Bernard by
finding an investor Gucci's ability to
hold their own against one of the most
ruthless businessmen in the world if
potential investors much more confidence
and this is when a man named Francois
penault would enter the scene they saw
admits that he had no clue who Bernard
was but not wanting to ignore any leads
the soul would agree to meet up with
penant in early March it turns out that
pennant was one of France's about
wealthiest businessmen and owned
Classics like Christie's Auction House
Converse shoes and Sam's net mortgage at
the meeting they saw would give his
classic speech about how he and Tom Ford
saved Gucci from bankruptcy and how they
were not trying to save Gucci from yet
another demon Bernard was impressed with
the first meeting itself but after a
second meeting that included Tom Ford
penult was sold he too wanted to move
fast in fact he wanted to move even
faster than Gucci as he didn't want to
lose the company to lvmh so he gave
Gucci an ultimatum finished the deal in
a week or I'm out they saw still had an
inkling of doubt if this was the right
choice but Tom Ford was confident that
this was the way forward which gave
desol the confidence to agree to a
multi-billion dollar deal in a matter of
hours by that evening itself they saw
would put together a confidential team
of investment bankers and lawyers are
all working to complete this deal
speaking of the deal the deal was that
they saw would issue another 40 million
shares of stock which Bernard would
purchase for 75 dollars per share this
would cost a total of its 3 billion
dollars and give penod a 42 stake in
Gucci while simultaneously downloading
Bernard down to 19.6 percent this would
essentially block out Bernard from being
being able to acquire a majority stake
but the deal didn't stop right there
either you see it cannot had another Ace
up his sleeve he suggested buying YSL
and letting desol and Tom run that
company as well this itself was an
extremely generous offer but what made
it even more satisfying was that Bernard
had just passed up on buying YSL a few
months ago so that he could focus on
getting Gucci and now Bernard was gonna
lose out on Gucci and YSL desola and the
Tom would of course take prenat up on
this offer and in the blink of an eye
Ruchi would go from trying to escape
Louis Vuitton's clutches to insulting
Louis Vuitton Bernard would of course
throw a tantrum he would sue to block
this deal and offer to buy the entire
company for 8.7 billion but now Gucci
had the upper hand and they weren't
gonna tolerate any more of Bernard
Antics and eventually Bernard had no
choice but to keep his minorities take
or just sell it off and move on and
that's exactly what he finally did in
late 2001.
in the end Bernard's hostility actually
ended up working in Gucci's favor not
only were they able to escape of the
image but they were able to find someone
that was willing to back them and to
truly form a mutually beneficial
partnership we should also mention that
Pinot made an awesome deal as Gucci now
accounts for 60 of its company's revenue
and 70 percent of his company's profits
it did end up working out just fine for
Bernard as well as he's now the world's
richest man but with that being said
that doesn't change that he was shown up
and outsmarted by a small company and it
just recovered it from near bankruptcy
and that's how Louis Vuitton got
humiliated trying to acquire Gucci did
you know about this corporate bloodbath
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're glad that Louis Vuitton got a
taste of their own medicine and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggested video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
but until then I'm Harriet and I'll see
you guys on the next one
foreign